okay oh good okay move it yeah they're
definitely not safe for children I think
I had some like workout Barbies but I
don't really know if those are 90s or
not Tetris is that maybe it wasn't Ginga
with it is like a soccer ball pers is
more fun than a pillow fight you know
nothing's better than encouraging kids
to be violent what could possibly go
wrong
boot up saga whoa I like it I reflected
that detail I'm feeling bad about the
wit the good thing about this is like
you're playing kind of by a lake like
maybe on vacation you fall in oh yeah
you can use that like a floating device
this is the first time I caught a punch
it a girl okay this is a good stress
reliever
I guess you learn self-defense or like
an early age GU green get it smells like
what are you supposed to do with this
look if it makes like fart sounds I used
to like imagine myself being slung like
I turn on the shower head and be like
whoa yeah I feel like it would be kind
of weird to like play with this for
hours on end it's not like play tall you
can't shape it and it can't copy things
as far as disgusting sound being
juvenile I love it
oh I know it's harder than it looks I
got it good okay wait
oh my gosh oh god I'm gonna hit my foot
I feel like I'm wearing one of those
things that people in jail where again
it's a workout I would play this for
hours and then like sleep it off
yeah I hate it I think this is so fun
what how many children like me would
crack their face open not say again with
the bright colors the veil code like
really nice makes me feel like I can
actually play ball this game was created
now you'd be able to throw it from this
as well
press like a button and there's a button
it'll release where the ball is like a
hologram this one's actually like the
most fun so far ah I feel so athletic
this looks not safe at all is it illegal
I feel like there could be a lot of
broken ankles I feel really tall this is
like adult assembly required oh my gosh
I got bored of those carefully just
walking around cuz I'm on the moon we
can't like makeshift these look they
just look like I know with like some
rubber bands I can like make music
videos moon shoot it was actually a lot
of it it's kind of fun to just stand
like this well the moon shoes were
pretty fun even though I don't
understand them
I think these toys are pretty awesome
nowadays kids are always with their
tablets and their iPhones this is
something that you don't see kids
playing with nowadays everything is so
much more complicated it teaches you
about being active and being healthy I
think they're perfect for children my
knees toys are pretty awesome